hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to guess
what we're still in sequel enjoyment
well perhaps some of you remember my
first crossover review affirm though it
was one of the first crossover reviews I
ever did that needless to say the film
was less than breathtaking it required
some help something nostalgic hopefully
volunteered herself to review the film
with me but little did I know that an
even greater evil just lay behind the
corner a direct-to-video little
abomination simply known as ferngully to
the magical rescue and see how the
nostalgia chick helped me last time I
figure it's only fitting to make the
offer again so what do you say miss - a
chick you're ready to go into the rain
forest one more time
no okay this is Fern Gully -
it's strange I mean was the frist
ferngully
really popular enough to spawn a sequel
I mean even a direct-to-video sequel or
the really protestors out in the streets
demanding to see more ferngully my
kisses the movie broke even which in
Hollywood means they can squeeze a
little bit more tried out of it which
resulted in this half-assed
effort of stinkiness but is it really as
bad as the first one or does it have
some redeeming value I think you ever
nice to make that Thompson let's dive
right into Fern Gully - so just like the
first movie they like to throw in songs
that really have nothing to do with
furthering the story and more to do with
you know I have no idea what they threw
in songs you know I can't really get
into a song that I swear I heard from a
foodie marshmallow krispies commercial
in the 90s so we see krysta from the
last movie showing some of the younger
animals the ways of Fern Gully you know
like how trees are good and people are
Hitler we also come across some of the
side characters like the beetle boys
same thing we do every night try to take
over the world and pips
Christa's possible boyfriend / possible
brothers / possible friend possibly
funcly' is the most beautiful place I
know but let's face it boys it's the
only place I know then I get tired of it
sometimes yeah so as you can probably
guess pips is turning into a Disney
Princess as he dreams about a world
beyond what he's used to fucking spoil
Brecht
[Music]
beat that Crysta Magi lune taught me
that magic is too precious to waste on
silly games I much rather use it to have
strange hand sex and impress mullet use
that aren't interesting enough to be
featured in the sequel but Christa
continues to help grow more trees in the
forest as again pitch can't help but act
like a loudmouth pussy just what we need
another tree big deal the forest is full
of them
personally I'd like to see something new
[Music]
suddenly in comes bed not voiced by
Bravo lanes but that's fine we seem to
be on a roll of not including any of the
same voice actors I wouldn't mind too
much except they don't even attempt to
make it sound like Robin Williams they
make him some more like Rip Taylor with
his testicles being demolished
I may be Patti brown not Nadia I'm out
of here but ghosts I'm history of a
hologram you can't see me bye-bye now
though I just hope they picked me for a
jackass 4d because I don't need this I
was in the Tom and Jerry movie but it
turns out Fern Gully is under attack by
one of the worst animals the planet has
ever known
yes man your name's Shane but satanic in
spirit man likes to spend most of his
time destroying things because he is
worse than the devil if he was a
pedophile
you can spot the especially bad ones by
having two-dimensional personalities
being written horribly and having to
change size that even first symbol with
each other so they kidnap animals burn
down rainforests and probably select
with your mother if you should see man
anywhere in your neighborhood please
make a pretentious animated feature when
confuse morals and no sympathetic
three-dimensional villains ah if there's
anything worse it's not human so as you
can imagine an evil poacher comes around
and steals the baby animals what are you
looking at now something I never
understood in this movie or the last
movie for that matter is how come Krista
who was clearly seen shrinking down the
main character in the last movie doesn't
just shrink these guys down to make
things a heck of a lot easier boy I'm
gonna get you guys real good end
so the poachers sleep well knowing
they've caught some tasty ingredients
for White Castle as our heroes try to
sneak up and rescue up careful boss
don't want to burn down a thousand years
of rainforest do we oh why not after all
we are good man yes bad shape no I got
the idea let's just get out of the
magical rescue oh hey we're at the
magical rescue already
I guess this movie's gonna be over a
snap boys we found ourselves some action
[Music]
what what so the fairies tried to save
the animals but have no such luck
[Music]
big-lipped alligator moment
Wow that was like the kangaroo version
of platoon
[Music]
the next morning they take a look at the
damage which of course results in a slow
spin of the burndown forest and just up
the ante let's add some hand to face
action there oh yeah human side there's
so much healing needed but some things
my dear even with all our magic do not
trend quickly
wait a minute whoop saw her grow trees
like full-grown trees in seconds what's
this a dune of men quickly bullshit she
can move very quickly hell she could
probably touch an impotent person to
make what growth me and the beetle boys
would go after those smooths and rescue
the babies the town is no place for
little bugs like you it's full of weed
killers television texts attorneys
completely unreasonable car insurance
hey modern-day references I'm coming
with you they're gonna be batty not to
be afraid of humans I mean if you ever
seen one eat an oyster it's terrible eat
an oyster because if he can't be funny
be confusing and we're trailer love for
The New Yorker so you realize pretty
quickly that the main character in this
one is not krysta nor is it the human
from the first film
it's pipsqueak here remember that guy
you barely saw in the first movie he's
the star now because krysta has to stay
behind and rebuild the rain forest
you know these movies don't really
convey how fragile the rainforest is do
they everytime they burn that shit down
they just magically drop back again why
don't you just save it the fairies
inhabit pretty well under control
[Music]
you know another pet peeve that gets to
me it's the fact that these fairies are
flying yet their wings never move
you got a flap a menorah to fly guys
hell in a lot of shots they don't even
have wings they just suddenly disappear
it's almost as if somebody just grabbed
them and throw them across the forest
yeah maybe that's probably get around
you really think you look cool wearing
that you know you look like a dumbass
you know the angry video game there is
much better than thank you
so they come across a carnival because I
guess carnivals are very popular in
their rainforest now if they decide to
check it out
[Music]
what's that noise
oh my god this carnival is awesome makes
you totally forget about the little baby
animals we're supposed to be saving
so as they're enjoying their antics in
the human world suddenly something dawns
in their heads babies
so knowing time is of the essence the
clue gets their focus back on track and
decides to hunt down the babies by
sleeping interesting strategy
better get some sleep human fun takes it
out here let me tell you maybe the
answer will come to me while I snooze
why haven't we been cut back home where
Krista you know the person who should be
the hero of this picture is seen trying
to grow fern going back to roots and
stems again even though we could see her
grow trees in the nanoseconds just sound
like a broken record
oh poor creature I just want to help you
he'll die if we just leave him here
please help him yo lucky I can't refuse
the fairy request it is the law of the
iguana so Krista and the not tome loaf
lizard get him out of the trap and heal
his wound with a leaf yeah just a leaf
probably got it on loan for that force
of improbability and quest for Camelot
she taught us to get the dog home
leaving that whole rebuilding the
rainforest thing as we see our heroes
come across an old man and his
granddaughter trying to perfect their
climate Oh bud G you've got no sense of
balance I don't think you're ever going
to be ready for the clowns like this I'm
ashamed to do what I do but I'm a
fucking clown did that human are you who
what are you a fairy of course of course
this is my first time out of Fern Gully
Fern Gully so she takes the whole seeing
half naked fairy thing pretty good and
she invites them to rest inside her
trailer yeah because if there's anything
they haven't done enough of its resting
meanwhile daddy who surprisingly seems
to be the holy character doing any work
in this movie
locates the animals and trusts to tell
the rest of the gang where they are hey
check this out
River on River River river off sign on
sign up sign on foot
our heroes everybody has your child been
kidnapped by unspeakable evil well we'll
do our best to eat your ice cream and
flick the lights on and off until your
child is rescued why was it Kristen if
you're gonna watch this
I'm sure Stan use gently on that
sinister square okay it's Sean Connery
doing that famous sinister square line
from fuck were you pulling it yep Oh
[Music]
budgies gonna take us on some rides
later if you want to come it's not like
there's any other important things we
could be doing right now I'm going to
rescue that baby just you huh uh-huh
okay partner it's just you and me I
don't even know what that impression was
so I can't really make fun of it so
badiy and one of those little minor guys
from Megaman go to save the animals but
unfortunately get caught kinda silly
when you can clearly see you can slip
right through the bars but hey if it
keeps them out of the movie I'm good for
it so literally as the fairies just
continue to ride the rides for the past
five minutes the animals and their cages
decide
somebody has to entertain the audience
so they break into an annoying musical
oh I just wanna curl up my boy the
animals are having a musical know that
until the spotlights are put in to
create a dramatic atmospheric
environment God can't help it if
everybody
[Music]
oh no they got music from Disney's
Hercules
[Music]
what's gonna happen to us Madi zoo
exhibits laboratory testing handbags you
no wonder all the gory details
oh my she was singing about how they
should never give up and find their way
home and now literally the very next
line he's talking about how they're all
gonna be handbags what up lifting leader
you think Georgia Patton did the same
thing the Nazis are the enemy waited to
them spill their blood shoot them and
the ballet oh my god I'm so afraid so
Pitts once again gets reminded about why
the fuck he came here in the first place
what is it pips what's wrong there's
something about this place budgie I
can't concentrate I came here because
two humans came into Fern Gully and
capture baby animals that's horrible
I'm supposed to be looking for them but
this place is so distracting is this
what you humans call a dee dee I feel
like I can't focus anything was why so
they finally decide to go after the
friggin animals as they chase down the
truck that's taking them away even the
girls grandpa gets caught up in the
chase it's hopeless
we gotta catch him come on Wow
motivations
hey was just putting that out of my
hands when I said she could really do it
but by God she could really do it so the
poacher sees the girl and naturally
pulls the truck over to stop her or she
does this really stupid thing you
freaking dumbass she's like 12 you don't
need to take advantage of the shaky car
ride just pull the dancing over and take
her off you're in big trouble
not girly there goes half of my animals
[Music]
yeah I'm calling bullshit on this one a
back carrying a little girl oh gee so
the old man finds out about the fairies
and decides to help them out
I blew it I spent so much time thinking
of myself that we've lost the babies
I've got a few tricks up my sleeve this
thing comes with all the options no no
actually it turns into a floating cup
imagines to find its way to where the
poachers are trading the animals they
managed to get them all but the poacher
doesn't let them get away that easily
[Music]
this is no time to practice our activity
okay I don't want to know what kind of
act requires her to pull his pants down
but it's probably called Theia Resta
crap but what a coincidence
Krista and the dog happened to show up
at the exact same time to help them out
so the animals are saved and our heroes
find that they finally have to say
goodbye goodbye pips
goodbye budgie
[Music]
that was heartless my baby mrs. cherry
hey mom what's for dinner
no Gert I love you mom
and it was also pretty heartless
all-around heartless that seems to be
the theme for the movie everybody you
know outside of the entirely unnecessary
as sequels go of us isn't one of the
worst especially seeing how they didn't
have much to go from in the first place
but it's just pointless the animation is
standard and at times praise sloppy the
story doesn't really tell us any more
about Fern Gully
or the characters it's just sort of a
road trip and even that's not
entertaining I like the idea of the
fairies getting distracted by the
attractions of the human world but it's
not fleshed out enough and it's not just
makes the characters look shallow on the
whole it's not god-awful it's a look at
sort of blase and forgettable which
considering sequel month isn't that bad
hell if I get a few more of these I
might be able to get through this after
all so tell me what is the next film
anyway
[Music]